so the the main detriment is that in the
u.s
the government doesn't care what we
think
uh or what's good for us
that's like the fundamental problem
that's a pretty big problem i i will
agree with you that's a big issue yeah
yeah they don't understand technology
either
uh their
resources on these issues are generally
the tech companies themselves
one organization doing great work on
this space politically is common sense
media which is largely a group of
parents who figured out that this stuff
is toxic for our kids it's run by a guy
named jim steyer
um so there is uh and the data by the
way is like if you ask parents hey would
you want
common sense regulation on
apps uh so that our our kids brains
aren't fried shockingly most parents are
like heck yes
and then
uh and then the but the parents feel
right now to completely outgoing they're
largely ignored
by congress
um so
one of the approaches i've taken which
you might appreciate johann is
uh this is a very american argument um
and it's also very me um which is to say
look look
our data is ours um we should not allow
these companies to essentially sell and
resell it for hundreds of billions of
dollars for their own benefit we should
get some of that money
uh or we should say we can turn it off
and there is some legislation in
california
that inaugurated a new consumer data
protection agency
and we want to replicate that nationwide
so if you are someone who lives in a
state other than california you should
be yelling at your state legislators hey
how why do californians have data rights
that we don't have
um i started something called the data
dividend project trying to get people
paid for their data which you could you
can and when listening to this can look
up or or join
now uh the short-term way to get people
money is successful lawsuits against
tech companies which most people don't
hear about but yahoo and facebook
and tic tac or paying tens of millions
of dollars for screwing up with people's
data and then
you know no individuals might get 60
bucks or 80 bucks but hey you know it's
like like that that's like a beginning
um because my thought on this is that if
you can get people excited about their
own data rights and possibly getting
paid for them
then you can catalyze more popular
excitement
around trying to beat back the tech
companies
but there does need to be
legislation there does need to be a
movement the problem for us here in the
us johan is that you can have a movement
and it just falls on deaf ears
in dc and congress
another thing i've done to try and make
these things happen is i've started
hiring lobbyists
on capitol hill who are just like hey
you know what people would like
child tax credit they really love that
thing hey you know what people would
like some common sense
restrictions on some of these social
media apps so that their kids are more
sane and healthy
so i'm working it but you should know i
completely endorse everything you're
saying and we need to go further and
upend the business models of these
companies because everything else is
going to be a half measure
i think what you're doing is so
important and i write about it in the
book and i'm passionately in favor of it
i think there's another level at which
your work can help us to solve another
aspect of the attention crisis if you're
right for me to talk about that because
and it's another place we have a cameo
in the book so i think the way into
understanding it is to go back whatever
it is 18 19 months now to the start of
kovid so when lots of us realize we were
going to be shut away in our homes
many people
um
i remember a lot lots of people saying
oh i'm going to be shut away at home
fridges i'll finally read war and peace
i'll learn french i'll you know people
had these big ambitious attention-based
projects
and
no one read war and peace and no one
learned french you know what we did do
johan we we did watch tiger king
well that was yeah that was that was um
like a horrific fever dream as far as
i'm concerned but the the googling of
terms like how do i get my brain to
focus increased by like 300.
if you want to understand why i think if
you understand why people found it so
hard to focus under covid it leads to
one of your big and best and most
brilliant issues
i interviewed a woman called dr nadine
burke harry so i think you might know
she's the surgeon general of california
yeah
ace the the trauma research she's
brilliant a complete hero i mean one of
the most remarkable people i've ever met
yeah people who don't know nadine i
really recommend people look look her up
and look up her work she's uh
an extraordinary person fighting for
some of those vulnerable people
and and and they didn't explain to me
when i interviewed the stress this was
pre-covered so i'm interpreting it in
like but she wasn't doing that um
she said to me look imagine one day
you're walking down the street and
you're attacked by a bear out the blue
and you survive
in the weeks and months that follow
something involuntary will happen to
your attention you will become more
vigilant so it'll be harder for you to
focus on things directly in front of you
like a book because a big part of your
mind will just be scanning for risk and
danger it's completely involuntary
because something attacked you out the
blue so your mind is just like geez what
else is going to attack me out the blue
okay now imagine you were attacked by a
bear again
you might well flip into a state called
hyper vigilance hyper vigilance is when
you cannot focus on the thing in front
of you because you are so anxious about
what might just hit you out i just want
to say if you get attacked
by dance twice
then you're being careless what's the
thing oscar wilde said you know uh once
it makes a misfortune twice begins to
look like carelessness i agree like are
you like walking around bear territory
with like a snake attached to your back
this reminds me of uh so i'll finish
this point about stressing it about uh
vigilance in a minute but it reminds me
of one of the worst things i've ever
witnessed in my life which is i once
gave a speech in banff
and i was in a place where
they um
there are bears so they give you bear
spray you know it's like mace you spray
into i mean no one had ever been
attacked by a bear but just in case as
you're walking around they give you m
they give you bear spray but there was
someone there who didn't speak english
very well and she misunderstood it and
she thought bear spray was like bug
spray that you spray it on yourself no
she sprayed it into her own face it's
designed to stop a bear and she sprayed
it into her own face it was horrific
anyway so
set aside that horrific image so if
you're attacked by a bear again you will
likely go into a state called hyper
vigilance and hyper vigilance is where
you cannot focus on the things in front
of you because you are scanning for risk
and a wonderful child psychiatrist in
adelaide in australia said to me
deep focus and attention are a really
good strategy when you're safe sitting
down and reading a book is great you'll
grow you'll learn more
deep focus is a very stupid strategy if
you're in danger right you want to be
looking for out for risk if you're in
danger you'd be a fool if you sat at the
battle of the somme
and and you know and and read a novel
right
so
we can focus best when we feel safe
one of the things well i think in covid
we couldn't focus because we were scared
of the virus we were scared that our
lives had been profoundly upended we
didn't know what was coming next we're
in this bizarre situation
but i also think it helps us to
understand another factor that's been
undermining attention for a long time
which is financial insecurity there's
evidence the more financially insecure
you are the more you struggle to focus
and it's a bit like the bear attack
if you've ever been broke and i have and
there'll be lots of people listening you
have
one thing going wrong can screw you
right one financial setback one one flat
tire yeah one broken washing machine
bill yeah
exactly as you talked about so
brilliantly during the campaign
um so
you can see that we're flipped into this
mode of hypervision and the reason this
is so important is in finland as you
know much better than i do they did an
experiment with a universal basic income
where they chose a group of people at
random and they gave them uh i think it
was 750 us dollars a month and there
were many interesting results all of
which your listeners don't need to tell
them about because you've
you're far more articulate on this than
i am
but there was a really interesting one i
interviewed professor alavi kangas who
did that research monitor was in charge
of monitoring the outcomes
one thing they found was a really
significant improvement in people's
ability to focus and pay attention
if you give people a baseline of
security and stability
they are safer and they can attend more
to what's in front of them
and then they're less vigilant there's
other interesting research on this
there's a guy called sending milal
nathan professor milan nathan did this
this this research that reinforces this
point
he studied indian sugarcane farmers
and basically because it's seasonal at
the start of the season they're broke
they've burned through their money from
the previous season they're broke and
then at the end of the season they are
um
they've got much more money
and he tested their iq when they were
broke and when they had money they
scored 13 iq points better when they had
money than when they didn't because it
just screws your intelligence and it
screws your attention if you're anxious
and scanning for risk
stress
if we anything we do that reduces stress
improves and enhances attention over
time another is the increasingly
invasive technology and some of the
effects that it has on us there's also a
whole range of obviously 10 other
factors
let's let's do the inventory like go um
and you we don't have to go through all
10 list style but but some of the others
are
uh nutrition exhaustion pollution uh but
yeah just because i'm sure for most
people going into this they were like
okay this is a tech thing um but it is
much bigger than that well that was what
surprised me
in a way i started to think about the
tech in relation to the other causes
because i started to think of the
technology as like a virus right it
would have been potent at any time but
it arrived at a moment when our
collective immune system was already
down because there had already been a
big series of changes that were
profoundly damaging our ability to focus
and pay attention i'll give you two very
quick examples
we sleep much less than people used to
we sleep an hour less than people did in
1942 children sleep 85 minutes less than
they did a century ago and when children
don't sleep they become manic the last
quarter of the book is all about
children and what's happened to them and
i spent a lot of time interviewing the
leading experts in the world on sleep
and there were so many chilling moments
on this but one was with a guy called dr
charles seisler have you ever spoken to
him if not i really recommend having him
on your show oh i'll enjoy you if you
want a completely amazing man and and he
did a series of experiments that really
haunted me so one of the things he
discovered is if you stay awake for 19
hours which really doesn't sound like
much to me
your attention becomes as bad as if you
had got legally drunk if you just go for
nine days
only sleeping six hours a night your
attention becomes as bad as if you were
legally drunk i'm pretty sure i did that
on the presidential but
you were all drunk
yeah i can't imagine the horror of that
and and um he did this experiment where
they combined two forms of technology
they put people in a machine that can it
scans your eyes and sees what you're
looking at and it scans your brain to
see what's happening there
and what he discovered is when you're
tired and you don't have to be that
tired
literally
whole parts of your brain have gone to
sleep the technical term for this is
local sleep because it's local to one
part of the brain so you appear to be
awake but you are half asleep um and
this is because i also want to explore
this a lot and i go through it to a lot
in the book but um dr professor roxanne
prichard a brilliant person at the
university of minneapolis where i
interviewed her explain to me the key
reason key reasons why
when your brain when you're when you're
sleeping your brain is repairing itself
it's cleaning itself your cerebral
spinal fluid channels open up they're
rinsed through with a watery fluid that
carries out all the metabolic waste
which she calls like brain cell poop
that builds up throughout the day
carries it down to your liver and takes
it out of your body if you don't sleep
your brain does not repair properly and
so it's it's literally impaired and she
explained of course we evolved so that
you could sometimes go without sleep we
wouldn't be able to raise children or
escape hurricanes if we couldn't do it
sometimes
but when you don't sleep your body
interprets that as an emergency
and it puts all sort of emergency
measures in place it stops you thinking
about other things it lowers your
cognitive ability it raises your heart
rate it raises your blood pressure it
makes you crave more sweet snacks so
that's one example right we sleep dr
seisler said to me even if nothing else
had changed even if all that happened is
that us and our kids sleep much less
that alone would be causing a really big
attention crisis
[Music]
you